the fed are they just being little
uh uh little babies and they don't want
to actually raise rates by 50 basis
points what's going on with the 25 base
bringing a water gun to an inflation war
yesterday no yeah i mean so these guys
are firefighters right i mean that's it
let me imagine like the the you know
bring showing up to 911 with the water
gun and that's effectively what they're
doing um you know so the markets enjoyed
that yesterday
a lot of what happened with the market
response um it's a function of the
derivatives markets dynamics you have
opex options expertise this uh tomorrow
and so a lot of those puts are coming um
they're coming off the table and that's
causing this sort of mechanical lift to
the market but the reality is
the fed more or less told you yesterday
they're going to mechanically raise
interest rates and mechanically shrink
its balance sheet until they break
something now they're never going to say
we're going to break something um and
that's in that sort of um that's sort of
implied by their uh their growth
forecast where growth never goes below
trend employment rate never goes above
trend um but they've got uh interest
rates uh if you look at um the dot plot
um going both above trend and so it's
pretty clear that
the markets and the economy are on a
collision course uh for the fed to break
something it's just a matter of when not
if
is it guaranteed that they're gonna
break something it's not guaranteed but
let's be let's be realistic right like
the fed
operates in this sort of
vacuum whereby they believe monetary
policy has quote unquote long and
variable lags that's one of the
creepiest things they say they always
say it and like look chase scheisty when
they say it but i mean this is true
right we know monetary policy operates
with long variable lags but those lags
have become shorter right um there's so
much forward guidance now every time
they open their mouths the markets take
what they're saying and reprice it into
bond markets into rates markets into
equity markets etc and so those lags
have shrunk over time it's impossible to
measure how long the lag is but what i
mean by this is um at the end of the day
they're not going to know they've broken
something until it tel to the markets
tell them they've broken something
that's the problem inflation's not going
to come down fast enough to get them off
of this policy path
why did they only do 25 basis points and
not 50. were you surprised by that uh no
i'm not surprised by it because the
markets are pricing in 25. um if you if
you look at sort of the fed does not
like to surprise markets at least not
going back to the bernanke fed and
yelling fed greenspan wouldn't mind
surprising obviously paul volcker didn't
mind uh pissing people off but the
reality is in this new fed regime it's
very unlikely that the fed will ever do
anything that's not priced into the
market for that meeting and so only 25
basis points were priced in and part of
it obviously we've got a lot of
volatility russia ukraine is a big uh
head
big risk but the reality is
they don't have a choice they're doing
the littlest they possibly can do but
they're going to do the littlest they
possibly can do for as long as they can
possibly do it until something breaks
so is it fair to say they're just going
to keep doing like 25 basis points every
meeting as of right now unless something
changes just 25 basis points every
meeting until inflation comes down yeah
so i mean we obviously going back to our
uh last week's discussion you know we
all know at least the four guys in the
room are four and a half five guys in
the room uh we all know that inflation's
gone up in march i don't think anybody's
gonna be shocked by that
um we could see in may when the fed does
its meeting in may it's very likely that
they outline uh quantitative tightening
which is when the fed shrinks its
balance sheet basically sends all the
liquidity uh dynamics going in the
reverse way um for risk assets and so um
we're going to get uh the data on that
they might choose to to speed up uh
their policy tightening projections or
tighten at 50 basis points to that
meeting but what's more likely to happen
is they maintain this sort of 25 basis
points per meeting
outline and just use the balance sheet
as kind of the flex tool if you will
yeah it's um
does that mean that recession is the
only
outcome now like like if they keep doing
this then we just get recession yeah so
it's it's here's a problem again with
markets right the fed believes and
according to their dot plot according to
their projections michigan are
ridiculous um they're going to take so i
sent you a few church i don't know if
you had time to load them up or not but
um one of the charts is is called dot
plot where we show uh the feds um you
know the two year the two-year uh the
one-year and the two-year forecast for
the fed funds rate relative to their
long-run rate and this is the first time
if you look at their two-year projection
that we've seen the dot plot their dot
plot go into restrictive territory i.e
they think the federal funds rate's
going to be higher than the level of
federal funds rate that is that'll cause
the economy to slow and so you know
that's a meaningful signal and of itself
but they didn't change their gdp or
their unemployment rate projections to
say that they're going to go below trend
they're going to go below
a level that is sort of indicative with
the healthy expansion so
that's a ridiculous expectation and so
to answer your question when we go into
recession there's no guarantee that we
have to go into recession is that the
conditions are in place for a recession
to occur particularly given that the fed
is likely to be tightening for longer
than it should
and started later than they had started
later this is the lowest i told you i've
talked about this for a while now this
is the low that was the lowest the
unemployment rate has ever been pri at
the beginning of a tightening cycle
that's the second tightest that the
yield curve has ever been if you look at
the tens two spread um at the beginning
of a tightening cycle and so you know
what those e2 indicators are telling you
is one the unemployment rate being as
low as it is that we're pretty late in
the business cycle and then number two
the the yield curve being as tight as it
is as narrow as it is it's telling you
that we're not only late in the business
cycle but we're already slowing
cyclically uh to a place that you know
to undetermined location but that
undetermined location has a very high or
very reasonably high probability of
being a recession hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time